Thank you to Private Internet Access
for sponsoring today’s episode! PIA
provides a secure, reliable VPN connection.
Click the link in the description below to
receive 82% off the first two years,
plus four free months of free service.
It’s pretty fun to watch organisms eat in the
microcosmos. There’s a whole range of methods
to enjoy. You’ve got single-celled organisms
slowly absorbing prey into their bodies through
phagocytosis, rotifers whirling the crown of
cilia on their head to get food into their mouths,
and so many other techniques that shape the life,
and death, of our invisible little friends.
And at the core of all this is a simple,
universal need: energy, energy stored chemically
as adenosine triphosphate—or ATP—that’s
made from the breakdown of sugars and fats.
In bacteria, the production of ATP happens
at the cell surface membrane, with protons
and electrons traveling at the borders of the
organism to drive the creation of this fuel.
And the process is similar for eukaryotes. Except
unlike prokaryotes, eukaryotes have organelles,
specialized bodies inside of them to
carry out special chemical reactions.
And there is even anorganelle dedicated
to making ATP. Perhaps you have
heard about it? The mitochondrion? Better
known as the powerhouse of the cell.
Yes the powerhouse of the cell.
The origins of that phrase seems to come from
a 1957 Scientific American article written by
Philip Siekevitz that was titled “Powerhouse
of the Cell.” It’s gone on to become
such a ubiquitous way to describe the organelle
that it even has an entry on knowyourmeme.com,
which says, quote, “the phrase is typically
mocked as an example of impractical
information taught in public schools.”
Obviously, we at Journey to the Microcosmos
would never mock an organelle, especially
one that is making it possible for us to do
just about every single thing we are doing
at this moment. But we would like to take
a moment to maybe, lightly question some things.
Because is the mitochondria always the powerhouse
of the cell? No. Not for all eukaryotes.
And this matters because it shapes the way we
understand the evolution of eukaryotes.
There’s a story about giant amoebas that
we’ve shared before but we want to talk about it
in more detail today because when you’re talking
about exceptions and nuances to a commonly stated
scientific fact, those details are fascinating.
We also want to talk about it because
we want to talk about diplomonads
and to share, again, one of our favorite
historical observations of the microcosmos.
In the 17th century, the original master
of microscopes Antoni Von Leeuwenhoeck
woke up with some, less than ideal bowel
movements. But Leeuwenhoek knew a good
opportunity when he saw one, and he took his
watery sample to the microscope. He wrote:
I have at times seen very prettily
moving animalcules. Their bodies
were somewhat longer than broad, and
their belly, which was flattened,
provided with several feet, with which they
made such a movement through the clear medium
and the globules that we might fancy we
saw a pissabed running up against a wall.
Clifford Dobell, Leeuwenhoek’s biographer, took
this description and matched it to the medical
knowledge available to him in the early 20th
century to diagnose Leeuwenhoek with giardiasis,
a disease borne out a parasitic diplomonad
that colonizes the human intestine.
Now not all diplomonads are parasitic, but they
are all just a little bit weird. For one,
they have two nuclei. They also have eight
flagella trailing behind and around them
as they spin through the microcosmos.
What makes diplomonads really weird
is that they do not have: mitochondria. This
puts diplomonads into a small and exclusive
club with a handful of other eukaryotes.
These organisms, which scientists grouped
together into what they called the Archezoa, are
anaerobic, meaning they don’t need oxygen and
might even prefer to live away from it.
And that would explain why they might not
need mitochondria, which require
oxygen to drive their reactions.
But it does not explain how they got that way.
So scientists worked with the information they
had at the time to come up with an explanation, an
explanation that would later be proven wrong.
They reasoned that diplomonads and their fellow
Archezoans got that way because they just appeared
a little too early. Mitochondria are thought to
have been the result of an endosymbiotic event,
where at one point in eukaryotic
history, one cell engulfed a prokaryote.
But instead of getting digested and consumed,
this little prokaryote inside of another cell
became useful in a different way. It became
an organelle. And the diplomonads, scientists
thought, just missed out on that big event.
Except, it turned out that the Archezoa might
have gotten in on the mitochondria party, they
just also left it, losing theirmitochondria
to evolution’s inventive ways.
In the process, the Archezoa were left with
genetic mementos from their former organelle.
One of the unique facets of mitochondria is
that they have their own DNA, separate from
the DNA of a cell’s nucleus but still able to
instruct the production of proteins necessary
to the mitochondria. But what became clear is
that there wasn’t nearly enough DNA
to encode for all of those proteins.
In fact, the mitochondria only produce a
small fraction of the proteins they need,
around 15% according to one estimate. The rest
are encoded by DNA in the nucleus, transferred
there at some point by the endosymbiotic
prokaryote that would become the mitochondria.
This fact became important when scientists
realized that some of these genes could be
found in diplomonads and their fellow Archezoa.
Genes that encoded proteins usually associated
with the mitochondria existed in organisms that
were thought to have missed out on mitochondria
entirely. Which meant that perhaps they
had not missed out on mitochondria. Maybe
they had had mitochondria and then simply
traded them for a different way of life.
Now while there was always the possibility that these
genes could have come from some other source,
that alternative seemed increasingly unlikely
as it became clear that Archezoa have organelles
similar to mitochondria, just rewired to suit
the chemical needs of these anaerobic organisms.
In the diplomonads, the organelle is called the
mitosome. But curiously, despite the resemblance
to mitochondria, the mitosome doesn’t actually
make ATP. It’s mostly known to make clusters
of iron and sulfur used in many cellular
functions, including metabolism. Instead,
diplomonads make ATP in their cytosol, that
soupy mix that surrounds their organelles.
Other members of what was once called the Archezoa
have their own mitochondria-like organelles,
capable of making ATP. And the result has
been a challenge to the story previously told
about them, that these were early progenitors of
eukaryotes, simpler than what would come after.
If anything, it seems to be the opposite. These
organisms likely evolved with mitochondria like
their fellow eukaryotes, but they also
evolved out of them. Which means that
there are so many other questions to explore.
Questions about how organisms found their way
and survived in anaerobic conditions.
Questions about how mitochondria have
evolved. And questions about what the origins
of eukaryotic life would have looked like.
And as for the diplomonad, I suppose we should
say that the cytosol is the powerhouse of the
cell. And the point is not to poke holes in a
popular biology aphorism taught to students.
The mitochondria is the powerhouse of the cell
for many, many organisms, including you.
But when it comes to evolution, the
exceptions to the rules we think define
us are the source of incredible futures
written in mysterious and varied pasts.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thanks again to Private Internet Access for
sponsoring today’s episode. PIA provides a secure,
reliable VPN connection. Now you might
be asking yourself, “what's that?”
Well, a VPN is a Virtual Private Network,
it encrypts your internet data,
and hides your ip address, keeping your
information secure and protected. But it
also allows you to watch streaming content
that may not be available in your area.
So, if you’re wanting to watch a certain
Seattle hockey team play their games,
but your sports streaming service won’t let
you because you’re technically in the local
viewing area even though you live 500 miles
away from Seattle, you can do that with PIA!
Private Internet Access works with all major
streaming services, so you have access to all
your favorite content anywhere in the world.
And PIA is available for all platforms,
and one subscription protects up to 10
devices at the same time. And PIA has a
next-gen server infrastructure covering over
83 countries and each and every US state!
You have a 30-day money-back guarantee if
you don’t like the product or if it doesn’t
meet your expectations, and right now PIA
VPN is offering Microcosmos viewers their
best deal yet, an 82% discount + 4 free months
when you use the link piavpn.com/microcosmos
That  link will be in the description.
Thank you to all of the people who are on
screen right now. They are our Patreon Patrons,
and they allow us to uncover all these very
bizarre mysteries about life on this planet.
There are certain folk who’d like to look a
little deeper and like to see things a little
stranger. And these are definitely some of those
people and if you are interested in supported us
so we can make videos like this, the link is
Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro. If you want to see
more from our Master of Microscopes, James Weiss,
you can check out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.